plus les jours passent plus l'attention
de l'élection présidentielle qui aura
lieu en mai 2022 se fait sentir plus les
candidats potentiels ou déclarés
aiguisent leurs arguments il y en a 1
d'ailleurs qui aurait pu aiguiser un peu
plus sa proposition c'est le député
européen europe ecologie les verts
yannick jadot
que propose-t-il une tva à zéro pour
cent sur les produits bio afin d'inciter
les français à consommer plus
responsable et soutenir une filière
d'avenir
sauf que cette promesse serait bien
difficile à tenir car depuis 1977
les taux de tva font l'objet d'une
harmonisation européenne
le but limiter la concurrence fiscale
entre les états membres et que certains
états se transforme en grands
supermarchés à bas prix au détriment des
autres la france peut toujours décider
de son dos mais elle doit respecter
certains seuils européens en deçà
desquels elle ne peut descendre il y à
un seuil notamment pour les produits de
base dans lequel d'ailleurs on peut
mettre les produits bio ce seuil c'est
5% vis-à-vis bertrand tenait un candidat
à l'élection présidentielle avait
proposé de le faire pour les produits de
première nécessité si on veut donc
descendre en dessous des 5%
il faut donc réviser la directive
européenne sur la tva
et pour cela convaincre les autres états
membres et le parlement européen
rien d'impossible dans 2018 l'union
européenne a révisé cette directive de
77 pour aligner le taux de tva de la
presse en ligne sur celui des
publications papier dans un souci de
promotion du pluralisme de la presse
donc pour aiguiser sa proposition
yannick jadot devrait donc précisé que
lui président il ne serait pas seul à
décider
sinon tout ça n'aura été qu'un coup
d'épée dans l'eau
fou